Okay, so one nice thing about the memory
protection stuff we've been talking
about is that it could be used
to create these fences or
isolate these different
applications from each other.
I was talking about process A cannot
access memory that currently belongs to
process B.
But the same mechanism actually could be
used to isolate the operating system.
Remember, we wanted to tamper
resistance for the operating system.
You shouldn't be able to alter from
untrusted application code, so
we can isolate the operating system
from untrusted application code
using the same memory protection
mechanisms that we were talking about.
So the way we do that is we're going to
say the operating system, also called
the kernel, is going to reside in a
portion of each processes address space.
So the address space in which
the process executes now has two parts.
Where the user code and
data is going to go, and
where the operating system is going to
go, operating system code and data.
So the OS resides, and
that part of the address space is common
across different processes, is going
to be a portion of the address space.
So think about the address space.
There's a user portion, a user area, and
then there's the OS, or kernel, area.
And this holds for each and every
process that we have in the system.
And remember that we talked about
system calls and things like that.
Whenever you want to go from the user
portion of the address space to
the system portion of the address space,
that transfer has to be special and
handled by the operating system.
It can only be done through the system
call that we're talking about.
So one way I want you to think
about it is that, but so
this is the address space
that process A executes in.
Then we said there is this fence or
boundary.
The OS goes here,
the user code goes here.
And when you are here,
when you're executing this portion,
you're not allowed to access
this part of the memory.
Remember the execution mode
that we're talking about?
So the hardware is going to save you
in the user mode, and you're asking for
an address here,
that's not going to be allowed.
So the way all operating system is
isolated from application code,
which is untrusted, is essentially
putting those in separate places, and
making sure when you're here,
you can't go into the operating system.
Well, we said that call gates are
controlled entry points through which
you can come in, but then we're
coming in by making a certain a call,
the operating system understands,
and the operating system is going to
do whatever checking it needs to do.
And then you're going to be executing in
the operating system while you access
anything here.
And when you're done, you're going
to return back to the user level.
So we use the same memory protection
mechanisms you're talking about,
base tables, protection bits,
what different base tables we have for
different processes for
the operating system.
So, remember, one of the things
that I can't overemphasize is
the operating system, or
the trusted computer base that we have,
has to manage these page
tables because page tables
control what portions of memory you
can access, and in what manner.
And the operating systems says, this
is your code, you can execute it, but
you can only execute.
Or this is your stack, you can
read/write it, but you can't execute
from it, that's a non-executable stack,
and things like that.
So this is how the operating
system is going to actually
protect itself from
untrusted process codes, and
also allows these untrusted processes
protection from each other.
So process A can't, for example,
corrupt the memory of Process B
because the way the address translation
and the protection mechanisms work.